we've already done multiple videos on
the crusades but what we're going to
focus on in this video is how the
crusades helped catalyze the start of
what many historians consider to be the
first international financial
institution and that is the knights
templar
so let's just make sure we have a good
hold on the context so over here we have
our timeline it's occurring during the
high middle ages
in other videos we saw the first crusade
start at the end of the 11th century
started really by pope urban ii with the
purported reason to help the byzantines
take land from the muslims especially
the holy land the first crusade is for
the most part successful but they don't
return that land to the byzantines they
set up what are known as crusader states
or crusader kingdoms including the
kingdom of jerusalem and just to read
this timeline that i drew up here green
shows the time period when at least
jerusalem is controlled by the muslims
red shows when jerusalem is controlled
by western european powers or by these
crusader kingdoms which were essentially
western european these red parts on our
timeline show when the actual crusades
occurred so you see the first crusade
causes the change of control of
jerusalem from the muslims to the
western european christians and once
jerusalem was under their control and it
would continue to be under their control
for roughly 90 years you could imagine
that many pilgrims from europe went to
the holy sites in the holy land
especially in jerusalem
but this was not an easy journey not
only was it a long journey these are the
paths that i showed in previous videos
that the crusaders took but this could
also be the paths that many of the
pilgrims took in order to go to the holy
land and you could imagine a journey of
this distance going through multiple
kingdoms in this time period could be
incredibly dangerous and many of the
pilgrims actually were robbed or
sometimes worse on their way to the holy
land
so in 1119 a small group of knights led
by oog depen
they go to king baldwin ii king
of jerusalem remember they set up this
crusader state the kingdom of jerusalem
headquartered on the temple mount and
these knights tell king baldwin ii and
warmond or patriarch warmond the
patriarch of jerusalem they say we would
like to protect these pilgrims on their
way to jerusalem
these guys think it is a good idea and
so in 1120 they give them some space a
headquarters on the temple mount in
order to start their group
if you translate the latin version of
their name it translates to
poor fellow soldiers of christ and the
temple of solomon
now the reason why it says
and the temple of solomon is because
they were headquartered on the temple
mount and the al-aqsa mosque is believed
by many to be on the site of the
original temple of solomon but this is
often shortened to the knights templar
this is their symbol two knights riding
on a horse to show their poverty but
they don't stay poor for long
they are shortly thereafter recognized
by the pope
and many people start donating money to
this order many more people volunteer to
be knight's templar
and so over the remainder of the
crusades they become an important
institution in medieval europe
now most folks often associate the
knights templar with being knights you
can see here one of the knights on
horseback here you see the knights
protecting pilgrims on their way to
jerusalem and they did do that they did
protect the pilgrims and they were also
active in battle during the crusades
thereafter but it turns out that even
though at the peak they were on the
order of 20 000 knights templar only
about 10 percent of them were actual
soldiers were actually these warrior
monks as they're sometimes called the
rest of the templars created this fairly
significant complex infrastructure to do
multiple things to support the goal of
the knights templar
and perhaps most significantly they
developed a sprawling financial
enterprise of the time
if you were in london and you wanted to
do a pilgrimage to the holy land you
would need resources in order to do that
and you would want to have access to
your wealth once you got to jerusalem
and so you could imagine if you're
traveling over a long journey to take
gold coins with you not only would they
be heavy but more importantly it would
be dangerous a lot of people might want
to take that gold from you and so one of
the services that the knights templar
developed was that
you could go to their temple in london
essentially deposit your money they'll
give you a note of credit saying that we
the knights owe you a certain amount of
money and then you make your journey and
when you get to jerusalem you can give
that note to the knights there and they
will give you your money now this is
something that we take for granted today
i can go to an atm machine anywhere in
the world and for the most part i can
put in my atm card and get access to
money
but there's a lot of infrastructure that
makes that happen today we have
telecommunications we have
satellites that help information go back
and forth we have servers that keep
track of all of that data they didn't
have that in the middle ages and so you
can imagine this is a very powerful idea
that i could deposit money one place and
then i could withdraw it someplace else
and we still don't fully understand how
the knights were able to pull this off
it requires a lot of trust and how are
they able to authenticate the notes of
credit and at any of these points now
not only did they do this type of
deposit and withdrawal in multiple
locations they also because they had all
of these deposits and people were also
donating money to them just to support
their cause they were able to provide
loans oftentimes loans to very powerful
individuals like kings and nobility they
were often brokers in major transactions
this is the reason why historians really
do consider them perhaps the first true
international bank
in other videos we talk about how an
1187 salahuddin is able to retake
jerusalem but then in the sixth crusade
and the barons crusades it goes back to
christian hands but then 1244 it's
retaken again by the muslims and it
stays under muslim control all the way
until the end of world war one
and so with jerusalem taken in 1244 the
whole goal of the knights templar the
whole purpose of their existence starts
to become less important although at
this point they are significant and
influential financial institution
as we go to the end of the 13th century
the whole crusader mentality starts to
lose steam you have the 8th and 9th
crusades but they aren't successful and
as we get into the early 14th century
you have this character philip iv
king of france and he has incurred a lot
of debt in order to have wars especially
with england and a good bit of this
financing comes from the knights templar
he is a powerful man looking for
solutions to his debt situation and he
realizes one solution is maybe just to
arrest the people who you owe money to
and then not only do you not owe money
to them but you can seize their assets
and philip iv does exactly that famously
on a friday the 13th in 1307
he arrests
many knights templars including the
grand master the leader of the knights
templar jacques demolay he tortures them
they eventually confess to a whole bunch
of things but then they retract that
confession and they're not willing to
retract the retraction and so
in
1314
jacques de molay as well as other
knights templar especially in the
leadership who do not agree to those
confessions are burned at the stake in
paris
and this is considered the end of the
night's templar although there are many
legends of how they have continued on
perhaps in secrecy so the knights
templar are to this day are a subject of
fascination there's many legends
associated with them but one of their
biggest historical contributions that
isn't often talked about but we know
happened is that they really laid the
foundation for what we today consider
modern international banking